[Musique]
alier sujet encore qui reste tabou ce
sont les femmes qui ont fait le choix de
ne pas avoir d'enfants deux d'entre
elles ont accepté courageusement il faut
bien le dire de dire à emmanuel franck
les raisons attention petites têtes
blondes
il est prudent de s'attendrir longtemps
les femmes ont dû jurer leur amour des
enfants et leurs désirs exacerbés d'être
mère certaines osent maintenant mettre
leur instinct maternel au placard c'est
le cas d'anne et de geneviève des
d'avoir un enfant mais des gouttes la
vision des femmes enceintes
il n'est pas agréable c'est le
désintérêt total de la chose
pas par parti pris particulièrement mais
surtout parce que j'ai envie de me
consacrer à d'autres choses et je crois
que pour avoir des enfants c'est un
choix et surtout une disponibilité de
temps qui servent à un petit pain pain
préfère faire d'autres choses me
consacre à la création de préférence
éventuellement l'écriture si je peux
cookies persévérer dans cette voie
être disponible pour mon travail et être
disponible pour ma vie privée ce qui
fait que évidemment comme une journée se
divise en 24 heures eh bien je n'ai plus
aucun temps éventuel a consacré à
d'autres activités
les harmonies tribu liste
ne pas être préoccupé par l'existence de
cadre à une responsabilité exercée sur
l'autre personne plutôt c'est très
égoïste
en voulant absolument se projeter et se
voir d'une façon narcissique dans un
autre enfant à la limite il vaut
peut-être mieux en adopter et prendre en
charge des enfants qui sont là général
les gens ne supportent pas du tout les
femmes qui ne veulent pas avoir d'enfant
quand on a des enfants on n'a pas besoin
de se justifier quand on ne peut pas en
avoir on a systématiquement besoin de se
justifier
et ce qui est insupportable c'est la
pression sociale sur les femmes qui ne
veulent pas la voir vers des eaux du
manque fiche complètement des hommes
sont en général les plus furieux contre
les femmes qui ne veulent pas avoir
d'enfant les femmes ne comprennent
parfaitement bien parce qu'elle voit ce
que c'est la vie quotidienne etc
les emmerdes on est tous en revanche les
hommes ne supporte pas des femmes qui ne
veulent pas avoir d'enfant et on se fait
agresser à longueur de temps parce que
je pense que c'est une remise en cause
très profond de leur propre sexualité
je suis tombé sur des médecins lyonnais
débile me faisant l'apologie de la femme
qui ne prend pas la pilule ou qui finit
dans un cas psychiatrique si elle prend
la pilule et quel nouvel enfant une
femme qui n'a pas d'enfants un monstre
une femme épanouie pas et c'est un
discours que j'ai entendu assez souvent
enfin bon passage chez le gynécologue
qui vous convient pas vraiment changé
séduira les mythes un quart d'heure je
veux
vie de couple très bien très solidaires
et très serré et avoir un troisième
personnage ou un quatrième même s'il
devait y avoir plusieurs viennent
s'immiscer à l'intérieur de ça je
n'aimerais pas j'ai une vidéo exclusive
m'intéresse c'est le couple a deux c'est
la dualité c'est l'association deux
personnalités adultes qui m'intéresse et
pas deux adultes face à face à un enfant
et il est vrai qu'une des raisons qui
n'ont pas arrangé
mon mariage et qui ont contribué à mon
divorce et que mon mari voulait des
enfants et que j'ai aussi souvent par la
suite après rencontrer des hommes qui
voulaient des enfants donc forcément il
ya un moment où on est obligé de se
séparer parce que je suis inébranlable
dans ce choix de 36 ans donc c'est assez
lucide un plus le temps passe j'ai
toujours envie et pas plus pas moins
donc ça m'étonnerait que je change
je n'ai pas un refus d'enfant j'ai un
refus d'enfants que je procréer mois
bonjour si j'avais envie d'un enfant
jeanneret d'obturer pas j'en adopterai
un lapsus intéressant oui et le
cameraman d'ailleurs de l'équipe lors du
tournage a été tellement choquée par ces
propos qu'il a agressé verbalement donc
l'une de nos témoins on est tout à fait
désolé d'ailleurs pour elle donc ça
signifie bien effectivement que c'est
vraiment le sujet encore tabou et que ça
ça c'est insupportable pour pour pas mal
de personnes est en route pour les
hommes
[Musique]